welcome everyone to our one another
demo on which we are going to see that
how exactly we can do the installation
of docker on the windows platform
specifically on windows 10. now docker
is something which is available for most
of the operating systems different
different platforms
so it supports both the unix and the
windows platform as such
so um linux through various commands we
can do the installation but in the case
of windows you have to download the exe
file and a particular installer
from the docker hub websites you can
simply google it and you will get
a kind of a link from where you will be
able to download the
package so let's go to the chrome and
try to search on for the windows stream
uh particular installer you will get a
link from docker hub you download it
you get the stable version you get the
edge version whichever version you want
you wish to download
you can download it so let's go back to
the chrome so here you have the docker
desktop for windows so you can go for
the stable or you can go for the edge
right so you also have the comparison
that what is the difference between
these two versions right
so um the particular edge version is
something which is getting releases
every month
and the stable version is getting the
releases every quarter so they are not
doing
much of the changes to the stable
version as compared to the edge there so
you just have to double click
on the installer and that will help you
to do the installation of the process
so let's get started so you just click
on the get instable version so when you
do that
the particular installer is going to
install now it's going to take like
around 300 mb there so that's the kind
of installed which is available
so once the installer is downloaded so
what you can do is that you can actually
go ahead and you can
uh proceed with the doing the double
click on this installer when you double
click on that
you have to proceed with some of the
steps like you know from the
gui itself you are going to proceed with
these steps so we'll wait for
10 to 20 seconds more and then the
installer will be done and then we can
do the double click and
the installation will proceed so another
thing is that uh
there is a huge difference between the
installer like for example in case of
unix the installer is a little bit less
but in case of windows it's
a gui is also involved and there are a
lot of binders which is available there
so that's the reason why you know the
huge size is there
now it's available for free that's for
sure and it also requires the windows 10
professional or enterprise 64-bit there
so um if you are working on some
previous version of operating systems
like windows 7 and all
you have the older version called docker
toolbox so they used to call it as like
docker toolbox earlier but now they are
calling it as a docker desktop with the
new docker
windows 10 support as such here so
another couple of seconds and then the
installer will be done
and then we will be able to proceed with
the installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads
and here still we have some particular
installations
or some download going on so we'll wait
for some time and
once the installation is done then we'll
go back and we'll proceed with
installation
so couple of seconds so it's almost done
so i'll just click on this one you can
go to the directory to the downloads and
you can double click on that also
but if you want to do the installation
you can click on this one also and it
will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done
so um a desktop a kind of a gui
component will open there so it will
start proceeding with installation so
it's
asking whether you want to add a desktop
the shortcut to desktop so you can say
okay i'm going to click on ok so it will
unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to
successfully install that is getting
unpacked over here
so it will take some time to do the
installation because it's doing a lot of
work here so you can just wait for till
the
execution of the installer to be
completed and once the installer is done
you can open your command line and start
working on the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart
so once that is done you will be able to
proceed further and you can just
you know run the command line and any
docker command if you can run so that
will give you the response whether the
docker is installed or not so you can
see here
that docker is you know something which
is installed so you can run like docker
version you will be able to get a
version
of the client when you do the restart of
the machine then at that moment of time
the docker server will also be started
and then this particular error message
will go off right now the docker daemon
is not up and running because
the installation requires a restart and
when you close on this one and go for
the restart
the machine will be restarted here so
this is the way that how
exactly we can go for a docker
installation and we can go on that part
so that's it for this demo i hope you
got the idea about it how to install the
docker onto the windows platform
thanks everyone
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here